with more than 60 million Americans now
out of work amid the corona virus
outbreak President Trump is trying to
make what he says is the biggest
decision of his life
I want to get it open as soon as we can
we have to get our country open I'm
gonna have to make a decision and I only
hope to god that it's the right decision
but I would say without question it's
the biggest decision I've ever had to
make
joining me right now is Mark Cuban owner
of the Dallas Mavericks he has hundreds
of his own businesses one of the stars
of Shark Tank mark
what decision shooting which should be
the criteria that the president keeps in
mind when he makes the biggest decision
of his life I think he needs more
information I think you can't just use
the death rates and the number of people
who are ill or sick or anything you've
got to go out and start talking to
businesses about what they see on the
other side I would do a survey I would
send something out to companies and say
when we open back up fully do you
anticipate a hiring the same number of
people be hiring more or three retaining
less and I would send out the same type
of survey somehow to employees and say
do you anticipate going back to the job
you left with a job that you were fired
from or do you anticipate going to it's
completely different job or do you
anticipate not going after a job at all
you don't want to work because we need
more information to try to give us some
indications of what things are going to
be like after this reset what are the
responsibilities of these business
owners I mean when I walk in with a
building should they be taking my
temperature on my forehead should I take
that avid test 15 minutes to see if I do
in fact have the virus get one even if I
go out to lunch do I take another one of
those tests
what should the businesses be prepared
to do first of all the businesses should
be prepared to introduce whatever
science the scientist tells us that we
need to introduce whatever dr. Fauci and
company tells us is necessary that's
what we have to be prepared to do but
along those lines where there's
uncertainty we're really going to have
to adjust our businesses you know
restaurants are going to have to realign
the tables within you know we're gonna
have to think about it the American
Airlines Center how we're going to set
people there's just so many different
variables that we have to consider um
but we're just gonna have to be agile
let's talk about sports for a second
Sports Illustrated said a quote that I
wanted to share with you and get your
thought on when Sports is going to start
again well was it going to come back
soon the quote we will not
sporting events with fans until we have
a vaccine that according to Zack Benny a
PhD and who wrote his dissertation on
injuries in the NFL do you agree with
that you know again I don't want to try
to pretend on the scientist I'm the
wrong person to ask on exactly what it's
going to take but you know there are
scientists that we trust and whatever
they tell us that's what the NBA is
going to do and I as an employer until I
have absolute certainty that my
employees are going to be healthy going
to work I'm not gonna ask them to do so
you know if I had to guess I do think
we'll play games without fans initially
and then as we feel more confident going
back to work and going into crowds then
we'll start to explore whether or not to
bring fans into arenas and stadiums be
very interesting because we have to 9/11
we definitely changed the way we did it
through the turnstiles you could have
the distancing going through the
turnstiles we could have every third
seat being sold there are things that
could happen but I imagine a guy like
you will be brought in on that thought
process because there's the science and
there's the practical I own a sports
team and I know if this is possible
right mark yeah there's no question I
mean you're gonna have to talk to your
customers you're gonna have to build up
that confidence we're gonna have to try
a lot of different things you mentioned
9/11 I think you know part of the
program where we're giving money to
Airlines one of the things that the
government may consider doing is pre
buying seats and you know because the
government spends a lot of money on
commercial travel so why not partner
with the airlines as part of this deal
and have federal employees do some of
the testing on flying on Airlines
because if we can build confidence that
you could travel in a plane comfortably
and without risk that's gonna start to
build the confidence that people can go
into confined places or where there's a
lot of people but that has to be part of
the program things that we look towards
because again it comes down to science
and building confidence so mark the
president of Tuesday is gonna name this
council about bringing America back
economically and putting us back to work
would you like to be on that council
would be considered yeah any way I can
serve my country I'm all in yes if they
ask me to I'd be happy to yeah it'll be
great sometimes the president watches
tonight and I don't know I know he's not
allowed to do much because we're all
sheltering in place so maybe he heard
that he'll call you
lastly the smoke is I hope so too
because the
one thing I noticed a matter which show
you on whether it's radio TV sports or
news you always use you're putting the
country first I have no idea how you
stand politically and I think that's why
people look at your track record look at
your resume look at your success and
they got to call your number
lastly the let's take a look at what's
happened so far with the 2.2 trillion
and how it affects affect small business
three hundred and forty billion dollars
do you think it's working um I think the
program is a good program I think the
execution has suffered some I think the
banks are acting too much like banks
they need they're gonna need to be
forced to say you know just give the
loans first and we'll deal with fraud
and problems after the fact because it's
costing us more in lost jobs and
companies going out of business by
holding things up and slowing down the
loans then it would cost us in fraud so
hopefully things will speed up and
hopefully we'll look back and just say
it was a slow week to start things off
um but right now it's a challenge for
small businesses and a lot of my
companies are really concerned right and
they can't tell you to retain labor and
then till you find your money so
elsewhere to pay your rent
take care of your lease and keep your
lights on and maintenance your equipment
the 75 rooms right it's it's not even
just about that particularly for
companies that have investors you know
there are certain things called
affiliate rules which the banks are
saying well you know what if you have
this investor or you have a company that
you you're connected with unless you're
a restaurant franchisee you may not be
able to get these loans and there's so
much conflicting information on that
affiliates program that companies that
have taken in investors and more than
you know 50 percent of companies have
taken in investment at some level are
really freaking out freaking out right
so let's drill down and talk to people
and then get the answers mark every Ben
thanks so much hope you get that call by
Tuesday me too thanks Brian
take care